uh
good morning
ready one second one second
okay i'm ready
hello i'm sasha larkin i'm a captain
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
here to bring you the preliminary
details as we know them so far
on officer-involved shooting number 18
for 2020.
the details as we know them so far this
morning december 8th
at approximately 1 20 a.m a call for
service was received of a burglary in
progress
in the area of tropicana and 215.
as officers arrived on scene and
approached the house they could see the
suspect inside the house
officers made entry into the house and
immediately saw the suspect
armed with a hammer attempting to attack
the homeowner
officers fired their weapons and the
suspect was struck
officers immediately summoned for
medical attention
and when they arrived unfortunately they
pronounced the suspect
deceased these details are very
preliminary as this is an ongoing
investigation
in the next 72 hours the sheriff or his
designee will come forward with a press
conference
releasing any updates to the case and
all bartymore body-worn camera footage
thank you sure what is the address
they're not releasing any of that yet
and then do you believe that this was an
intruder
unknown to the person yes was the alarm
go off or did the um
homeowner call the police um both the
alarm did go off and a call was placed
to
or from 911 you know i don't want to
make that comment yet because i'm not
sure
but i know a call came to
just the 911 there was there was two
people inside the residence other than
the suspect
thank you
did he go back to his car
you